ils ne sont plus que deux dans leur
enclos dans la nuit du lundi 6 mars des
braconniers ont abattu vince quatre ans
l'un des rhinocéros du parc de thoiry
arriver en 2015
ce accord n'a été signé une macabre
découverte mardi par la soigneuse
principal aux alentours de 9h30 et elle
est arrivée à la maison déry noël a
constaté que la porte avait été
fracturée qu'une autre porte à
l'intérieur de la maison avait été
fracturée et elle est retrouvée donc le
mal rhino vince mort dans son box
on part quand même du principe que les
animaux qui sont dans un parc zoologique
son protégé justement du braconnage
qu'on rencontre dans la tire donc là
c'est très très choquant un choc pour
l'équipe mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
parcs animaliers
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
événement se produit en europe en
afrique du sud le braconnage de
rhinocéros a connu une hausse
considérable ces dernières années en
2015 1175 rhinocéros blancs ont été tués
pour leurs cornes contre 13 en 2007 il
ya un mythe autour de la corne de rhino
qui est absolument pas fondées
scientifiquement mais il ya des
personnes qui croient que c'est
aphrodisiaques que c'est une cure contre
le cancer
alors que fin pas du tout c'est comme de
la kératine c'est comme les cheveux
c'est comme les ongles sur le marché
noir
un kilo de corne peut être vendu 50
mille euros le parc est équipé de
caméras de surveillance
selon sa directrice les individus
connaissait les lieux le domaine de
thouars et va porter plainte
une enquête est ouverte